hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna talk about the 2019 remake
directed by Tim Burton of the classic
Disney animated film Dumbo electric nope
that doesn't work and works for two
electric boogaloo in some ways this kind
of does feel like a sequel yeah like
half remake half sequel definitely
builds out from the source material
yeah goes expands upon like especially
we see the trailer I think you could
sort of piece that together especially
since the original done though I think
is 25 minutes long full disclosure
Disney pays us quite a huge lump sum of
money to recommend their films this
apartments paid for for the next year
and if this video hits 10,000 views we
get an additional 250 bucks
so Dumbo is the best movie I've seen all
year so far yeah forgetting game forget
anything else just just if you see one
movie all year or go watch Dumbo make it
repeat viewings of Dumbo yes honest
sincere note I think Dumbo and if you've
seen ok dumb bug is an elephant birthed
into a circus has big floppy ears and
everyone freaked everyone that mean
about by now you could fly cuz
apparently in the 40s everyone's a jerk
right 40s or 30s doesn't matter the
olden days I think the best part of this
movie is the most important element to
it which is Dumbo Dumbo is adorable the
best character in the movie but the best
Depok actually goes to Dumbo but yeah it
doesn't even talk stirring on yes right
like the most emotions I felt were a
hundred percent for that elephant and if
there's any joy or Wonder that goes on
in this film I think it comes in the
scenes with Dumbo when he's learning to
fly overcoming fear those moments hit it
dawned on me about halfway through the
every case you guys can pick up on the
sarcasm we don't like this movie halfway
through this home I was like even if
it's like Dumbo or the N
aren't talking in this movie I think it
would have been cool if you did kind of
a quieter movie that you know was like a
body language movie these animals are
primarily Dumbo I feel like that would
have been even more effective instead
what we got here a film that is
simultaneously flat and loud as [ __ ]
like it doesn't have a really coherent
or discernable pace at least for me so
yeah it just feels like you're walking
through a series of different rooms that
all have a whole bunch of stuff going on
in them and there's nobody really to
help you get oriented John I grew up
with huge Tim Burton fans remember he
has like displays a lot to LACMA Museum
I tuned in for that some of my favorite
films I think come from Tim Burton's
filmography and it seems like after
Sweeney Todd he just and I know there
are some people who really love this and
I'll also say this I think kids will
actually I think just kids
I think there's some adults who have
definitely been recommending this movie
but I think kids will really like this
film a lot especially in its
construction yeah I feel like there's a
lot about this movie that is very
straight forward especially in the
dialog and the storytelling and so I
think for kids that actually might be a
good thing so for the demographic and
needs to primarily hit the main
demographics being hit I feel like you
know this is all a preference of
standards or what you expect from
because I feel like some of the
live-action remakes have been pretty
great of what Disney has had to offer
I appreciate the effort I'll say that
too I appreciate the effort because
rather than just doing a shot-for-shot
remake they had to expand on this
because Dumbo is such a short animated
film so I'll actually like the idea of
really trying to do different things or
add a lot in the thing is I feel like
most of the things they add in it's just
messy there's a lot of focus on the
humans in this movies
I feel like Tim Burton has sort of
evolved into his own version of Michael
Bay in a way where it's like very
self-indulgent CGI reliant that a lot of
earmarks of modern Tim Burton I've heard
quite a few people use this analogy
actually because you know we talked to
people after the screening it's kind of
like how transformers does a lot of
human focus characters in a film where
you should have just focus on the
Transformers it's kind of like what you
get here you know the humans in this
movie
like you sure you got a great cast in
here you got Colin Farrell Danny DeVito
Michael Keaton Eva Green you got a lot
of great actors in here yet the
characters in here I don't connect with
any of them yeah they feel very - to me
they feel like a combination of half-ass
retreads of Tim Burton characters and
Disney get like the father care does
that Colin Farrell plays I've seen him
in like three movies from Mary Poppins
returns the dad who's not good with his
kids or Christopher Robin the dad is not
good with his kids and then Colin I like
this is a trope that I'm seeing a lot
and that's also in a lot of Tim Burton
movies - bad parenting yeah one this one
was arguably the weakest for me on that
front
especially because what I'm starting to
realize is that with the more these
live-action remakes dozen he's been
doing you can spot certain elements that
are kind of the same every time and for
me that definitely came in the harried
father aspect which like I worked a lot
better from an Christopher Robin because
in this movie every time Colin Farrell
borders on having an actual conversation
with his kids his character literally
just tells them to go away yeah and and
they never really have any kind of
relationship id's who more than the
adult actors in this movie the kid
should have been the most developed
because they're the ones who connect
with Dumbo the most important
interaction with Dumbo in this film I
wasn't exactly sure what was going on
with him the daughter especially I feel
like she's supposed to be you know
emotionally detached or whatever she
doesn't wanna be part of this circus
family that she's involved with she's
got that Tim Burton teeth thing about
her where she's kind of wide-eyed and
and she's missing as a scene where she's
spinning yeah yeah she's got that going
for her but she's very bland well cuz
they don't give anybody a character
trait beyond here's your one thing like
the daughter the thing that bummed me
out about the daughter especially is
that her character trait is just
shoehorned in it so she doesn't like the
circus she wants to be a scientist cool
that's a very woken now message to have
that the movie doesn't ever bother to
turn into a real character that's most
of the characters Colin Farrell for
losses or losses are more like that's
his character doesn't really factor into
a
the movie and even though it's such a
big part of the the beginning it's the
set up and that could've easily been so
emotional yeah I'm touching the circus
family that you know the Dumbo and and
all the people are part of I felt like
they really missed the mark there man I
mean we've seen Tim Burton toy with
circus environments a few times now yeah
it is a great job there and then here
well I found very distracting on a CGI
level there's a part in that you see it
in the trailer so they go to a different
part that's not circus villa or the hell
they call it that I'm like okay that
makes sense why that's all CGI yeah what
did it make sense to me is why it's just
the immediate circus that you spent half
the movie with a regular traveling
circus when you're looking at the
environment I'm like why is all this CGI
I've seen big fish I've seen TV shows
that do this why is so much of this CG
you couldn't shoot this on location and
build a couple of sets see that's a
particular buffer to me about Tim
Burton's movies now is that for several
years up until this point they've
started to feel very synthetic to me and
they've always been heightened they've
always been stylized but especially the
more he relies on the CGI you just the
less natural anything starts to feel and
then when you don't have good writing on
top of that it all starts to fall apart
I feel yeah just kind of hollow sleepy
oh no Michael Keaton was probably the
weirdest part of this movie yeah when he
first showed up I'm like are you going
for like something subtle and then
suddenly it shifts into oh you're going
for like this weird chewing up the
scenery I heat intensely I have talked
with quite a lot of peeps about this
I couldn't understand half the dialogue
he was saying yeah I don't think it was
just the audio at the theater her
because I've talked to other videos on
different screenings and I'm like wait a
minute half of this movie I don't even
know what Michael Keaton's actually
saying in this Vil and it's another
typical Disney / Tim Burton villain
that's half me like we've seen that
villain a good jillion times oh yeah
especially in in this wave of rima I
mean he is the nasty mean evil corporate
guy yeah and somebody pointed this out
at the actual
screening and I do think it's an
interesting point is even though yeah
Disney likes to use that kind of villain
this time around it is especially
strange because they essentially
co-opted the circus and make it
Disneyland and so it's that much weirder
to watch Disney do that Michael Keaton's
kind of playing a Walt Disney kind of
cares yeah it's like what are you going
for here guys they're not expecting us
to sit here and be like this is
strangely telling yes I felt the best
performers were Eva green and Danny
DeVito
they were Leo they were the only ones
who really pry like genuine moments of
life or nuance in insert that doesn't
not enough to like be like yeah they had
enough moments that really that I felt
connected but you started to get pulled
in during some of their moments dobos
maybe at best half of this movie because
the other half is really dedicated to
all the humans who feel very halfway met
on the writing and directing of them it
doesn't really feel like anybody
directed the actors it feels like
everybody kind of made up their
character and just did the lines yeah
yeah and Colin Farrell reminded me of
george w bush most of the time I mean
his accent was kind of slipping and I
did want to go back to something you
said at the beginning because I do think
that some of the best moments in this
movie are when it is just doing visual
storytelling there are a couple moments
that are just set to music or that are
just between Dumbo and his mom for
example that are all about body language
and they're all about mood when the
movie gets out of its own way and
actually kind of works but there's so
few and far between I didn't walk in
going I don't want to see humans just
see Dumbo I fed any thing I left
disappointed cuz I was like well it
seemed like your potential for great
human characters was all here yeah it's
just nothing was met with a right
balance or tone and it honestly it's
just a really loud annoying film yeah
very annoying in the circus movie and
there have been several of those
throughout history and I feel like
circus movies especially are a great
potential to bring in suppressing human
stories as well like if we are going to
expand this I feel like you have a
built-in ensemble and built-in messages
to go with yeah you have this very
specific group of people who are in the
circus the freaks I couldn't tell you
what not
like most of whether who what their
specialties are that's such a specific
ingredient to an in Samba love circus
freaks yeah it's knowing oh this is what
this person does I can tell you what
like two of them do I can identify a
couple of the acts overall but they
never formulate into an ensemble of
characters overall I mean the title
character is the best part of this movie
it's the most important part I think
kids will like it for us personally it
was just a very bum me out yeah it
didn't have any finesse for me it just
seemed to have this weird kind of
homogenized pace we're just lurching
forward from one thing to the next and
after a while if you're not invested I
think it's gonna be entirely pulled out
but but Greg and drawn like everything
yes we do the others we gave this review
is because we're trying to you know
satisfy those hate calls entirely just
an effort you really you really love
this movie we we're gonna hate all the
movies we review especially in games and
anything Disney anyway did you guys see
Dumbo are you going to see Dumbo
what you know what just come up with
your own question leave freakin a
question and somebody else comment
before this video is done I would like
to give a picture of the day shadow to a
man named Daniel Gallagher our handsome
friend from Scotland he's been part of
our patron page I first think least six
to eight months now you know quite a
long time so thank you buddy and we
talked a lot about movies I'm now
recalling that the first time we ever
spoke you were telling me that you were
finalizing stuff to become a pharmacist
yeah and one exam left this was way back
I think in like August of last year and
the amount of times we've talked
you've never updated me on what's going
on with your career there did you pass
the exam what's happening with your life
can you prescribe us scottish drugs
because scottish drugs i hear are the
best and they probably will make dumbo a
better viewing experience look at that
foot and elephant huh look at a flop
what's our circus freaks around here
chillin
Irish
looking for some sausage anyway guys
subscriber to reject nation click that
notification bell and catch guys later